[Music]  hello you're in great danger get out of  there now open safe house 6 welcome in  the Townsend agency  I run a covert group with exceptional  women so you guys are like lady spies we  work outside the rules in secret  together you may not know we exist but  we are always watching you are in the  presence of angels so you want to train  you be an angel hell yeah  give me my wings  [Music]  sit down keep your hands where I can see  them really not supposed to be touching  things in here unless you're supposed to  be touching things I mean you're  adorable J is that you flirting with a  handsome  [Music]  the best part is them taking down  international criminals with you guys  and the day-drinking that's what I like  the most  [Music]  so I can just take whatever I want Baro  is that an actual rule  [Music]  ain't no time to go to work  [Music]  [Music]  you